nous savons que la vie quotidienne est
la plus difficile on nous demande de
tout faire avec de moins en moins de
moyens
quand vous regardez simplement nos
structures à chaque fois je le dis comme
une fusion de communes communautés de
communes communautés d'agglomération
communautés urbaines département région
état je crois qu'à un moment donné qu'on
le veuille ou pas ce millefeuille
administrative
franchement il suffit pas d'en parler il
suffit pas d'être autres soit à
l'évidence les français n'en veulent
plus
ça coûte beaucoup trop cher et cet
argent qui était pensé avec toutes ces
structures pas par définition c'est
autant d'argent nous n'avons pas
consacrer à nos concitoyens
alors moi je vous dis la finance la dgf
dotation globale de fonctionnement
je sais pas si effectivement département
comme disait pierre bédier ap 0 nous on
n'est pas mieux loti en ce qui concerne
les petites communes
derrière quand vous donne 24 points de
type communes comme la mienne on vous
donne 24000 euros de dgf le lendemain en
poupe romain de 5000 au titre du spic tu
vas pourquoi une jeune mannequin du nom
pic 25 lendemain et le surlendemain
c'est le brief qui nous piquent notre
ville donc en gros en gros en gros on
n'a plus rien on n'a plus rien et on ne
peut pas répondre aux attentes de nos
concitoyens
alors moi je veux dire quand je regarde
la formule d'impôt vous avez tous reçu
votre taxe vous savez elle a pour
l'instant elle est vraiment en format
portrait et quand vous regardez les
lignes croient qu'ils peuvent passer en
format paysage
maintenant vous avez vu il y en a déjà
une ligne qui a encore indiqué la gema
pire on sait pas encore combien mais
elle y est déjà
donc l'année prochaine format paysage on
en aura encore un petit peu plus et puis
en fait en ce qui concerne nos
attributions nos pouvoirs
on nous a dépouillé mais pas depuis deux
ans depuis 30 ans par des promesses non
tenues d'un côté gauche et droite
réunies
et aujourd'hui on feint de croire
finalement ben on n'avait pas mesuré
tout à fait les effets de toute la
législation qu'on nous a imposée alors
moi je vous dit avant moi mon petit
village autour de mon village il y avait
dix neuf paroisses y avait dix neuf
jurés
aujourd'hui à toujours dix neuf
paroisses et a plus qu'un seul curé
j'ai l'impression que c'est un petit peu
ce qui est en train de nous arriver mais
comme je vous disais vous êtes des gens
formidables vraiment formidable et en
réalité s'il a plus personne dans la
paroisse puisque nous sommes issus de la
paroisse il ya encore le maire ou la mer
où la mairesse comme vous voulez et moi
je vous dis finalement aujourd'hui vous
êtes dessin vous êtes les saints laïcs
les saints laïcs de la république
n'oublions pas liberté égalité
fraternité
essayons aussi nous mêmes en ce qui nous
concerne de diminuer nos demandes
essayons est aussi d'arrêter de demander
des subventions en permanence ce biberon
lacombe va chercher tout le temps et
partout
soyons raisonnables et économe les
subventions c'est toujours bien parce
que c'est les autres qui payent mais les
autres c'est nous qui payons donc je
crois qu'il faut que nous fassions nous
aussi un effort faisons un effort sur le
millefeuille administratif je crois
qu'il est temps et de toute façon si les
politiques ne le font pas moi je vous le
dis dans tous les cas de figure le
peuple de dire ah et on sera balayée par
le vent de l'histoire
mais soyons optimistes nous n'avons
jamais été aussi nombreux je me réjouis
je sais qu'un à certains qui après un
mandat s'arrête j'ai encourage à
réfléchir un peu et puis peut-être que
sous la pression des amis ils arriveront
encore à se sacrifier
merci pour votre sacerdoce c'était
vraiment un 1 mois j'en suis un moi mon
huitième mandat monsieur je suis
encouragée pour effectivement par le
président du sénat de me présenterai un
huitième mandat
je réfléchis monsieur le président et je
vous donne la réponse tout de suite
c'est oui voilà même
et à monsieur le président du sénat
monsieur le préfet madame la présidente
de région
monsieur mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires j'ai vu des sénateurs
j'ai vu une députée monsieur le
président l'union des maires des
yvelines et en vous saluant chergui
c'est l'occasion pour moi de saluer
l'ensemble des maires ici présents ainsi
que leurs élus municipaux
le président du sénat a coutume de dire
que la commune est une petite république
dans la grande
j'ai envie comme un écho de lui dire ce
matin que le conseil départemental du
moins dans les yvelines essaye d'être un
petit sénat à côté du gant qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que au delà
des politiques normal que nous portons
au nom de l'état monsieur le préfet en
particulier les politiques sociales pour
lesquelles d'ailleurs nous souhaitons un
accroissement à la fois du périmètre et
de la cohérence
je pense en particulier aux politiques
de santé
car si dans la meuse je crois que c'est
dans la meuse ou qu'ils nous disaient
que c'était catastrophique que j' ai
marre non en saône et loire en pardon
dans les yvelines dans les yvelines ça
commence aussi à devenir très compliqué
et il ne me paraîtrait pas absurde que
le département soit sollicité au delà de
ce que nous faisons déjà avec les maires
c'est à dire ces maisons médicales soit
sous forme de subventions soit même en
les construisant et en devenant
propriétaire nous mêmes toujours est il
que au delà donc de ces politiques qui
sont les politiques de l'institution
départementale
il y a aussi tout un volet qui est un
volet essentiel c'est le soutien aux
communes
ce soutien aux communes vous avez eu des
inquiétudes chers amis légitime
nous aussi on en a eu quand
effectivement notre dgf a été a
pulvérisé passé de 150 millions d'euros
à 15 millions d'euros 135 millions c'est
à dire 15 % de notre budget de
fonctionnement
eh bien nous avons eu quelques angoisses
mais aujourd'hui que la situation
financière est rétabli
jamais je dis bien jamais le département
des yvelines
nora consacrer autant d'argent pour les
collectivités locales pour les communes
et les intercommunalités
ce sont de nouveaux contrats qui ont été
créées les contrats pour les
intercommunalités le contrat territorial
des yvelines
ce sont aussi les nouveaux contrats de
développement pour les communes moyennes
et puis bien entendu le contrat rural
plus qu' état d'un accompagnement de
l'effort régional intensifiés dans les
yvelines où je veux le dire ici de façon
très très clair il était légitime que la
région fasse que son contrat rural soit
adaptée à tous les départements mais je
remercie valérie d'avoir bien compris
qu'il était aussi légitime que dans les
yvelines où on a une tradition et des
capacités dead aux communes rurales on
améliore en quelque sorte ce contrat
aura par le contrat rural plus donc ce
sont ces deux piliers dans les yvelines
et en particulier ce pilier en direction
des collectivités territoriales que nous
mettons en oeuvre
de plus en plus vous disait un peu moins
de 100 millions de cette année plus de
100 millions dans le budget l'année
prochaine c'est donc un quart presque un
tiers de nos capacités d'investissement
qui sont remis aux maires parce que les
mères sont les interlocuteurs les plus
légitimes pour nos concitoyens il faut
leur donner plus de moyens il faut
renforcer leur pouvoir
il faut parfois j'entendais ce que tu
disais sur les dix neuf paroisses
1 mon cher président pellicier il est
même arrivé qu'on fusionne des paroisses
dans l'évêché
il n'est pas absurde je crois que deux
départements à deux communes l'ont fait
dans ce département les deux
départements c'est pour plus tard mais
deux communes ne l'ont déjà fait dans ce
département fin deux communes nouvelles
et bien cette logique aussi nous
l'accompagnons puisque à côté d'ici donc
à saint-germain-en-laye lorsque
saint-jean même à fusionner avec four
que nous avons apporté une aide
exceptionnelle à ce nouvel ensemble
formé puisque les 47 mille habitants ont
permis à cette nouvelle commune d'avoir
une dotation spéciale du département de
100 euros par habitant pour accompagner
cette fusion voyez donc bien que le
département met en oeuvre des politiques
au service des illinois mais en étant au
service des yvelinois nous sommes aussi
au service des communes yvelinoise parce
qu'elles sont le substrat sur lequel la
qualité de vie le bonheur de vivre en
yvelines se construisent merci monsieur
le président du sénat chea gérard
monsieur le préfet cher jean jacques
monsieur le président du département
cher pierre et bien évidemment monsieur
le président des maires des yvelines
chergui mesdames et messieurs les maires
et mesdames et messieurs les élus alors
la région s'est elle aussi un orchestre
de mer pas un sénat mais plutôt un
orchestre et mon objectif c'est que les
1270 maires d'île de france puisse
donner le meilleur de leurs instruments
et tout ça dans une harmonie d'ensemble
ce qui me conduit de temps en temps à
rappeler d'ailleurs à la maire de paris
qu'elle est mère dans une région où il y
en a il y à 1269 autres maires et des
habitants d'autres communes et que tout
cela doit se faire dans une solidarité
dans une solidarité régionale
alors moi j'ai trois choses à vous dire
la première c'est que évidemment et
comme l'a dit pierre j'ai été bien formé
par un certain nombre de maîtres
yvelinois et la région est là pour vous
aider vous les maires à construire votre
projet de ville c'est pour ça que nous
avons doublé les contrats régionaux 53
millions d'euros cette année consacrée
aux contrats régionaux je pense qu'un
certain nombre d'entre vous les ont vus
chez eux
et puis on va continuer aujourd'hui nous
n'avons aucune demande non satisfaite de
contrats régionaux
mon prédécesseur avait neuf mois de
retard et comment vous dire il
choisissait un peu les dossiers
quand je suis arrivé il y avait des
dossiers qui étaient vraiment en dessous
en dessous de la pile 1 la piscine de
rambouillet la piscine de
saint-germain-en-laye
les le contrat de versailles les
contrats les contrats des villes de la
vallée de seine enfin bizarrement il y
avait un certain nombre de villes qui
avaient été oubliés alors quand je suis
arrivé on les a sortis de la pile et on
les a remis sur le sur le dessus de la
pile nous on prend au fil de l'eau il
n'y a pas de files d'attentes sur les
contrats régionaux en ile-de-france 0
files d'attentes on a mis les moyens
pour satisfaire vos besoins et je sais
que l approche des municipales
évidemment les choses vont un petit peu
se tasser mais qu'elles vont reprendre
très très vite en mars après votre
élection avec vos nouveaux projets donc
on est vraiment à votre disposition sur
les contrats ruraux là aussi j'ai été
assez admiratif de ce que le département
des yvelines a fait avec son bonus
yvelinois sur les contrats ruraux vous
le savez la région a fait un pacte avec
les territoires ruraux qui était de dire
contrairement à ce qui s'est fait par le
passé les territoires ruraux représente
un sixième de la population 2 millions
d'habitants en ile de france
ils doivent recevoir un sixième des
crédits de la région ce qui n'était
évidemment pas du tout le cas les
territoires ruraux étaient les grands
oubliés et donc inspirés par ce qui a
été fait dans les yvelines
nous avons fait des assises du
patrimoine et dans ces assises du
patrimoine nous avons décidé un bonus
pour les villages un bonus patrimoniale
de 200000 euros pour chaque contrat
rural entend toute l'ile-de-france
évidemment pas seulement dans les
yvelines ça ça n'est pas possible pierre
mais mais mais c'est important que ce
soit pour tous les villages
deux cent mille euros de bonus pour la
rénovation d'un patrimoine remarquable
dans un village yvelinois est évidemment
franciliens et c'est très important
parce que je sais que les plus gros
travaux en regardant vos contrats ruraux
les plus gros travaux vous avez affaire
et ceux pour lesquels vous avez le plus
de mal à financer
parce qu'à pas vraiment de retour sur
investissement c'est la rénovation de
vos églises
l'art est tu as parlé des églises qui a
dit qu'il y avait plus qu'un seul curé
ne tient pas dit que ça coûtait quand
même cher à entretenir les 15 voilà donc
l'église pour moi c'est le coeur du
village le coeur battant architectural
culturel de convivialité de proximité
c'est le repère et donc egli
la voir grange patrimoine industriel
maisons remarquables et donc n'hésitez
pas aussi à demander le patrimoine
d'intérêt régional qui vous donne accès
évidemment à toutes les subventions que
ne vous donne pas les monuments
historiques ou que ne vous donne pas
l'état donc ça c'est sûr les maires on
est avec vous on vous aide et on est là
pour vous aider vos projets deuxième
chose que je voulais vous dire on parle
beaucoup d'écologie
en ce moment c'est très à la mode de
parler d'écologie l'écologie tout le
monde et écologistes sauf que nous on
était comme monsieur jourdain le
monsieur jourdain du bourgeois
gentilhomme de molière c'est que nous
les yvelinois les élus revinois nous
étions écologistes sans le savoir nous
sommes les premiers écologistes de
france le département des yvelines un
département magnifique qui conjugue la
ville et la nature de manière
extraordinairement harmonieuse et ça
c'est votre bilan vous êtes les maires
écologistes et l'écologie ça n'est pas
une étiquette politique
l'écologie c'est une façon d'aborder la
qualité de vie dans sa ville ou dans son
village et donc je revendique
aujourd'hui que nous construisions la
première région écologique
évidemment d'europe mais peut-être du
monde et c'est pour ça qu'avec gérard
larcher avec pierre bédier nous nous
battons contre une métropole riquiqui
qui serait réduite à la zone dense
parce que cette métropole riquiqui qui
n'intégrerait pas les espaces verts de
la grande couronne serait une métropole
anti écologique alors qu'une métropole
qui serait à lui département avec nos
forêts avec notre agriculture qui
seraient nourris par nos agriculteurs en
circuit court
il ya cette métropole là ce serait la
première métropole écologique du monde
et moi je vous invite à bâtir avec moi
cette région écologique et à en être des
acteurs et à le mettre au fronton de vos
mairies et c'est pour ça qu'en novembre
nous allons aller sur toute une série de
domaines dont vous qu'ils vont pas vous
permettre de d'avoir des projets
écologiques alors ça peut être sur le
vélo ça peut être sur le verre le
verdissement
ça peut être sur l'agriculture ça peut
être aussi sur les zones de non
traitement vous savez que le
gouvernement va prendre des arrêtés de
zones de non traitement pesticides
autour des communes
que va-t-on faire de ces bandes de
terrain autour des co
une il faut pas que ça devienne des
friches il faut pas que ça devienne des
dépôts des dépôts de toutes les saletés
donc qu'est ce qu'on va faire de ces
zones moi j'ai dit aux agriculteurs et
christophe hillairet peut-être par là
j'ai dit que la région était prête à
investir 2 millions d'euros pour qu'on
travaille sur ces bandes de territoire
est ce qu'on y met de l'agriculture est
ce qu'on y met de l'horticulture est ce
qu'on y met de l'agriculture bio est ce
qu'on y met des haies est ce qu on y
plante des fruits des fruits des arbres
fruitiers
bref je veux qu'on en discute donc sur
tous ces sujets là on reviendra vers
vous on aura aussi un plan solaire un
plan anti bruit monsieur benassaya on
aura un plan hydrogène donc sur tous ces
sujets là vous pouvez être moteur
d'innovation et on vous accompagnera et
ça ce sera tout ça sera annoncé en
novembre et la dernière chose que je
veux dire c'est que évidemment nous
aussi à la région souffre du
désengagement de l'état monsieur le
préfet et pour les yvelinois et je le
dis parce que je vais avoir besoin des
mères et de leurs soutiens
nous avons un besoin de transport et ce
besoin de transport nécessite que l'état
tienne ses engagements
le cpr le contrat de plan etat-région
s'arrête en 2020 en 2021 en 2022 si nous
ne voulons pas arrêter les travaux y
compris les travaux des hommes y compris
les travaux du tram 13 saint cyr
saint-germain y compris la rénovation de
nos erreurs qui sont tellement cruciaux
pour nous eh bien nous avons besoin que
l'état continue continue monsieur le
préfet de mettre 400 millions d'euros
par an c'est là par l'état n'a pas
région et de doubles de ses 400 millions
huit cent millions nous avons besoin de
cet argent
et moi je suis très inquiète parce que
ce que l'état a dit ce que le
gouvernement a dit comme il n'arrive pas
à faire des économies sur leurs dépenses
et qui sont impécunieux ils ont dit on
va détendre le calendrier du contrat de
plan état région en matière de
transports
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on ne
mettra pas un sou en 2021 2022 on va
vivre avec les crédits qui ont déjà été
engagées de 2020 ça ça n'est pas
possible donc je déclare l'état
d'urgence je demande à tous les maires
de se mobiliser pour que les projets de
transport continue pour que l'état soit
au rendez-vous et pour qu'ils ne se
défaussent pas en ile-de-france sur les
transports du quotidien merci
rim dit mot consent merci merci
c'est le président du sénat madame la
présidente du conseil régional monsieur
président du conseil départemental
le président de l'union des maires des
yvelines j'ai essayé de monter le ton
parce que les gens qui se gobergent
ferait mieux de baisser d'un ton enfin
bon je peux pas parler plus fort qu'eux
merci monsieur le président de me donner
la parole je vais essayer d'être aussi
brève que possible oui c'est ce que
j'aurais tout simplement dire que dans
le contexte complexe du point de vue
budgétaire et technique qui vient d'être
rappelé notamment par valérie pécresse
mes collaborateurs et moi qui sont
d'ailleurs présents ici nous essayons de
maintenir le lien de confiance
nécessaire entre chacun des maires et
chacun des conseils municipaux et les
services de l'état
c'est une objectif d'une grande humilité
mais nous essayons de le faire pour
renier ce que certaines lois ou certains
règlements ondes abrupte voire de
répressif
je pèse mes mots je pense évidemment la
loi sru mais pas que pour qu' un certain
équilibre une certaine possibilités
d'action des communes soit maintenue
voyez notre objectif est modéré mais il
est constant et puis nous avons des
problèmes plus graves affronter en
commande dont celui qui a fait l'objet
de la signature de tout à l'heure celui
qui me tient particulièrement à coeur
comme l'ensemble des personnes qui sont
à la tribune
c'est à dire celui de l'unité de la
cohésion nationale et de la fraternité
entre nous tous et nous avons vraiment
besoin de solidarité pour éviter que ne
se délite encore un peu plus le tissu
social est que ne s'altère le civisme
dans notre département
même si nous sommes encore très
privilégié à cet égard voilà tout
simplement mesdames et messieurs les
maires ce que je voulais vous exprimer
bien entendu nous relayons mes
collaborateurs et moi jusqu'à tard
général
pas pu venir il est actuellement auprès
du préfet de région précisément nous
relayons les besoins en particulier de
transports madame la présidente bien
entendu vous savez que dans la mesure du
possible notamment pour la rn10 nous
avons essayé de réintroduire malgré la
détente
certes un certain nombre de crédits dans
l'application du cpr qui fait un
problème bien entendu donc sachez notre
vigilance sur ces points budgétaire
comme sur les points techniques
il ya des lois qui ont été votées dont
la complexité pernicieuse continuent à
peser douloureusement sur les uns sur
les autres
donc à chaque fois nous essayons d'en
d'étendre la dureté dans un objectif qui
n'est pas de se soustraire l'intérêt
général mais au contraire de l'accomplir
dans l' équilibre je pense notamment la
construction de logements sociaux qui
est nécessaire mais qui doit se faire
avec l'assentiment de tous et donc pas
sous une contrainte inquisitoriale et
répressive voilà les quelques mots que
je voulais vous dire en vous exprimant
ma gratitude à tous pour la qualité des
relations que à 99,5 % des mères vous
maintenez avec nous un ou deux une ou
deux exceptions mais je citerai les noms
le moment venu et dans les réunions
publiques idoine mesdames et messieurs
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
bien là madame le maire de port marly
dans sa commune
[Musique]
monsieur le préfet des yvelines
monsieur le président de l'association
des maires des yvelines devrait s'élever
nos collègues membres de l'association
des maires des hauts-de-seine avec qui
nous avons partagé ce matin d'un salut
et bien sûr la présidente du conseil
régional valérie pécresse le président
du conseil départemental
mais nous n'allons pas nous quitter
puisque nous retrouvons à bourges ce
soir pour le congrès des départements de
france pourrait saluer nos collègues
députés et le collectionneur
je vois ici nombreux sophie primas
martov sidrac michel laugier alain
schmitz et je ne doute pas que martin
lévriers nous rejoindra je voudrais
saluer tous les collègues maires maires
adjoints conseillers municipaux salué
les présidents de compagnies consulaires
c'est vrai j'y reviendrai chambre
d'agriculture chambre de commerce et
d'industrie et les représentants des
chambres de métiers que je vois ici
c'est à dire que nous formons une trame
tous ensemble et vous tous mesdames et
messieurs à bord heureux d'être parmi
vous comme sénateur des yvelines
donc avec mes collègues sénateurs comme
celles et ceux qui ont reçu mandat de
votre part de les représenter au
parlement au suffrage universel indirect
pour être naturellement article 24 bis
de la constitution le représentant des
collectivités territoriales mais au
travers de vous aussi de représenter les
citoyens
merci à l'union des maires son président
à son directeur et à toute son équipe
pour l'organisation de cette université
qui est toujours un grand succès un
grand moment qui nous donne l'occasion
d'échanger quatre points très bref nous
avons signé tout à l'heure j'ai assisté
avec monsieur le préfet comme président
de la chambre des notaires
à l'enregistrement d'un engagement qui
s'appelle une charte de bon voisinage
entre l'agriculture les collectivités
territoriales l'état la région et les
départements
au fond au voisinage c'est ce à quoi
vous contribuez comme bear faire qu'il y
ait encore une cohésion et à chaque fois
qu'on peut avoir un bon voisinage
nous avons dans cette république divisé
fragmenter les occasions de nous
retrouver
je crois je voudrais remercier vraiment
aussi les agriculteurs je peux
comprendre toutes les réticences toutes
les interrogations
le sentiment parfois d'être abandonné eh
bien je dois dire qu'au contraire dans
ce département
ils sont pour nous des partenaires et je
pense que chacun des maires doit
comprendre qu'il est parfois bien de
prendre des arrêtés mais des arrêtés
pour envoyer des messages de mauvais
voisinage ne m'apparaissent pas une
manière d'avancer
la seule manière d'avancer c'est le
dialogue deuxième deschamps je suis dans
une ville où alexandre dumas a régné que
disent-ils ce sont les illusions qui
rendent les douleur amère et
inguérissable
alors mes chers collègues essayons de ne
pas avoir d'illusions et je m'adresse à
vous monsieur le préfet en saluant les
sous préfets qui sont ici autour de vous
de chacun de nos arrondissements et qui
au fond sont une représentation de
l'état comme je souhaite que demain la
représentation de l'état soit de manière
déconcentré renforcée car je n'oppose
pas la nécessaire décentralisation et
son approfondissement à un état qui soit
renforcée sur le territoire antagonisent
et les uns les autres n'a pas de sens
nous avons besoin les uns des autres
un mot simplement sur quatre textes nous
n'avons la chance dans le département
d'avoir une sénatrice qui s'appelle
martin sidrac qui vient d'être
rapporteur d'un texte sur
l'économie circulaire un mot qui veut à
la fois tout dire et rien dire sauf que
marc thaçi drac avec nous qui sommes des
acteurs depuis des décennies de la
collecte du traitement et du recyclage
elle ne s'est pas laissée à voir et on
lui proposait de recycler par la
consigne 7 % des déchets elle nous a
fixé un objectif de 90 pour cent pour
les cinq ans qui viennent et le faire
sans peser sur les finances des
collectivités territoriales et des
syndicats qui nous représente
je dois vous dire que c'est notre vision
concrète pragmatique de l'environnement
comme le disait valérie pécresse et sur
ce sujet là je crois que nous pouvons
avoir une politique environnementale qui
partent de la base le président des
maires du nord m'a dit en m'accueillant
juillet l'écologie punitive dans ol
fracturé le pays
on en a vu le résultat dans la révolte
des ronds points l'an dernier mais
l'écologie qui vient du territoire qui
vient d'en bas au fond elle peut y
compris en demandant des efforts
réconcilier et c'est une action que nous
devons conduire la seconde des choses
mais je reconnais que c'est que vous
vous apprêtez en 2020 à subir le sort
que la démocratie fait que nous nous
soumettons au citoyen d'abord remercié
tous les maires pour le mandat le plus
difficile moi courageusement j'ai quitté
en 2014
après avoir connu l'âge d'or et vous
avez connu l'âge de pierre de 2014 à
2020 baisse des dotations normes
intercommunalités forcé enfin tout et
tout et surtout le sentiment fort
heureusement aujourd'hui arrêté que ou
ne contient pas beaucoup dans la
république il a fallu il a fallu janvier
de cette année pour que on retrouve que
vous étiez les arcs-boutants de la
république je dis pas ça pour vous faire
plaisir
mais s'il n'y avait pas eu 35 mille mer
en france contenu la république
à un moment tout pouvait
acier et bien je ne suis pas certain que
la république serait dans le même état
parce que vous êtes profondément des
républiques trois textes un texte
engagement et proximité en cours de
débat cet après midi nous aborderons le
rôle et la place du maire une
intercommunalité qui soit coopératives
et mutualistes et non pas un acteur de
disparition du maire et des conseils
municipaux
une nouvelle analyse sur les compétences
une délégation de compétence donnée au
maire dans le cadre des
intercommunalités
quand il s'agit de sujets qui concernent
leur territoire et puis aussi la
possibilité sur le préfet c'est un
bonheur pour vous comme les présidents
d'unions des maires comme les présidents
de départements et de régions il n'y
aura plus de révision automatique tous
les six ans du schéma départemental de
coopération intercommunale nous avons
besoin de stabilité visibilité et de
prévisibilité puis naturellement la
défense des mères leur défense parfois
physiques leur défense juridique
tous ces sujets nous sommes en train de
les aborder second sujet qui vient qui
est en commission des finances
c'est après la disparition de la taxe
professionnelle
la réalité aujourd'hui de son
remplacement
vous allez donc recevoir le foncier bâti
de monsieur bédié est le vôtre vous
allez recevoir mais que vous n'avez pas
encore comme calcul c'est les
conséquences sur le potentiel fiscal et
pour reprendre une formule de claude fer
dont je le comprends jamais les analyses
mais qui s'avère vrai vous avez à risque
de tsunami fiscal avec la réalité de
l'incertitude voilà pourquoi j'ai
demandé je dois vous dire exigé qu'on a
une simulation commune par commune etc
intercours après à des recours avec
quand même un problème mes chers
collègues sommes heureux quand le
président du conseil départemental nous
accompagnent dans les politiques
territoriales quand ils nous
sociales
il faut bien mesurer que la conséquence
c'est la perte totale de levier fiscal
pour le département et avec la baisse de
dgf 90% que nous avons connues comment
aurions nous fait pour maintenir un
département dont nous avons besoin parce
que je crois fondamentalement au rôle
des départements
voilà mes chers collègues quelques
réflexions que je voulais partager avec
vous mais je n'aurais pas conclure sans
regarder les trois stands qui sont
devant moi et en disant au colonel qui
commande notre groupement maintenant 10
ans directeur départemental de la
sécurité publique
en dix ans directeur adjoint des
services départemental d'incendié et de
secours
un moment où parfois des images divise
les uns et les autres que nous avons
besoin des uns et des autres et que
notamment depuis 2015 monsieur le préfet
vous le savez la république peut compter
sur eux et je voudrais plutôt est un
rassembleur il paraît que c'est mon
métier mais nous avons besoin non pas
d'opposer les uns aux autres mais de
rassembler les uns les autres car il y
va de notre vie quotidienne jours et
rendre hommage aux femmes et aux hommes
de ces trois corps de ce qu'ils
apportent au pays parce qu'ils sont des
facteurs de cohésion est rappelons le
dans une république le respect de la loi
ça a du sens nous sommes donc à leur
côté vivre les yvelines et ville de
mulhouse
[Applaudissements]